hi martin i need your help sure lan
what's up
so i have built a report in looker which
is a business intelligence and big data
analytics platform in google cloud
another team that i work with use
bigquery which is a data warehouse in
google cloud so i need to export the
data in my local report to bigquery well
google cloud functions are great for
integrating systems like this let's try
it out
[Music]
uh before we start uh maybe you can tell
me a bit more about looker's
functionality since you are the looker
expert lan sure i would love to in
looker we have the actions hub which is
a feature that lets you send data from
looker to third-party products we call
it actions because we believe in
empowering companies to take useful
actions after data analysis for example
after analyzing data on customers who
are likely to turn we can send them an
email or text message to bring them back
okay that sounds great lan
so for this use case the action you want
to do is send data from looker to
bigquery yes martin i have my data in
transactional processing databases after
doing some live analysis using sql
statements of that data in looker i want
to send the result to bigquery got it
how do these looker actions work
so i need two urls to create a new
action the first url should return the
name and icon for the actions in json
looker will use that to display the
action in the user interface that makes
sense
it would be easy to create a cloud
function that returns a hard-coded json
object and now you said there was a
second function what would that one do
so the second url should do the actual
work looker will make an http post
request to that url with the user
selected data in the body the code
behind that url should receive that data
and write it to bigquery
i see
cloud functions are great at receiving
http requests and extracting any data in
the body
our cloud function i could then call the
bigquery api to insert the data into
bigquery easy peasy can the cloud
function run out of memory or timeout
cloud functions will automatically
provide an auto scaled https endpoint
for each function we write
and the second generation of cloud
functions lets your code use up to 16
gigabytes of memory and run for up to
one hour that's great martin let get our
hands dirty
we are writing two functions the first
function will tell looker about the
action's name and icon plus the url of
the second function the second function
will write the data to bigquery i would
like to deploy the second function first
so that i get the url to it
makes sense uh do you have the code for
it yes i wrote it up in python looker
will send a post request to it and
include metadata in the payload
including the download url which is a
one-time link to download the data my
code will open the download url save the
data that comes back as a csv file and
store it on cloud function temporary
disk
all right and now that the csv file is
on disk we can call bigquery's python
client library to load that csv file
into a bigquery table
and now that we have the complete code
let me click here to create a new cloud
function i'll pick python as my language
and then paste our code here
then i click here to deploy the function
it will take a minute for the deployment
to finish
when it's done i will get a url back
and anyone who hits that url will run
the code we just entered up in the cloud
now i will write the function that tells
looker about our new action
it will declare and return a dictionary
which includes the configuration for the
action in looker's user interface such
as name for the action what data format
it can take
url for the icon and most importantly
the url to the function we wrote a
minute ago the one that actually writes
to bigquery
okay i'm pasting the url into the code
you sent to milan
let's deploy this function
all right is this the final step plan
not quite martin we need to install this
action and local
are heading to looker
admins
action
and then add the url of our function
right here
the action has been installed
great now anyone on internet can call r2
functions
how does looker handle security
looker can send a secret key to our
function kind of play a password we can
validate that key in our code if the
request does not have the right key we
can ignore it but the key may change so
i don't want to hard code it into our
functions
no problem we can put the key in secret
manager and read it from there
so if the key changes in the future
we'll just update it in secret manager
and we won't have to deploy a new
version of our code so how does a cloud
function greet secrets from the secret
manager cloud functions can either mount
secrets as volumes and read them as
virtual files
or read them as environment variables
let's use the environment variable
method here
excellent i will add this extra logic to
our function
it compares a secret key that looked
consent with the one from the secret
manager
all right our functions are now locked
down so they only run if the caller
provides the right key
and we know that looker will
yeah let me see if our new action is
working i will try sending this table
which has around 1 million rows of
bigquery
this will take a little while should we
review our tea and meet back here in
five minutes let's do it
and we're back i can now see my data
right here in bigquery
it took around 5 minutes to transfer the
1 million record
wow no it's bad that's a little over 3
000 records per second
this is so great i love how cloud
functions bring us all together just
like a good meal
you're making me hungry lan
uh thank you everyone for watching if
you have any questions for lan or me
about looker actions or you have any
suggestions for future episodes please
let us know in the comments until next
time
[Music]